he is a sociology professor at
Georgetown and his latest book jay-z
made in America is out now our friend
Michael Eric Dyson is over
okay what topic would you like to talk
about first this man who stands up every
morning to excrete the feces of his
moral depravity into a nation he's
turned into his psychic commode that's
what I want to talk about the elephant
in the room you're wearing Kobe's jersey
there and I know you were great friends
with him yes absolutely absolutely uh
must be devastating as it is for
everybody it is extremely devastating I
went down to the memorial that makes
shift Memorial today a kind of living
breathing mausoleum on the one hand but
people's love for him was extraordinary
he was an extraordinary human being a
great great basketball player
I wrote the cover story for slam
magazine when he retired saying he was
the best and the thing about him that I
think is so remarkable this is stuff he
did behind the scenes so the activist
Shaun King called me up and said a young
man who had been shot to death by the
police his brother was in the car
loved cooked a brother who survived
loved Kobe Bryant he called me up I
called Kobe he sent him a bunch of stuff
and called him a young woman from Israel
contacted me and said I know you're
friends with him my brother has cancer
and he's a huge Kobe fan so I called
Kobe all they wanted was a little video
made on his phone to send to him Kobe
went to the studio and made a
professional video and sent to this
young man that's the kind of stuff that
was representative of him so
baby he is your next book I mean you
have written a lot of great biographies
you did Martin Luther King you did
Malcolm X you did Marvin Gaye my era
yeah yeah no doubt I love that know what
am i I mean harvest I mean help the
voice underrated and he's a huge star
right even in passing but still under a
Marvin Gaye is in my pantheon yeah yeah
you did a book about two o'clock I read
a book about people you did a book cult
is Bill Cosby right right I did but not
about but drugging women no it was wrong
and I had three page look this was in
what 2006 yes and before woke was woke
bra and like let the people in and I'm
holding Bill Cosby to account and I was
talking three or four pages about the
drugging of women and a lot of black
people get mad at me why are you trying
to take a brother down right I said no
he drugged us before he drugged those
women so now the book is about jay-z why
did you pick him well he turned 50 this
year you know last year right he turned
50 years old thirty years in the game
and hip hop was about forty years in
terms of above-ground so I wanted to
talk about this tremendous figure a guy
who was rhetorically fluid verbally
gifted but also commands the attention
of the world and I say in the book he's
like Robert Frost with a Brooklyn accent
Rita Dove with a Jesus peace and people
say well how dare you compare him I mean
if you listen to his lyrics the sympathy
of them are powerful what who says that
Bill O'Reilly knows a lot of people how
dare you compare a rapper do with Robert
Frost whose woods these are I think I
know as houses in the village though
well jay-z has some lyrics to that are
and he's got a Robert Frost never had to
rhyme Robert ortt isn't even even good
Oh
that's like one of those grandfathered
in one well two roads diverged in the
yellow wood and I took the one less
traveled by and that is made all the
difference
those woods these are I think I know his
houses in the village a pusher never
stopping by a woods but I us is to keep
in mind so before I sleep and miles to
go before us some say the world will end
in fire all right I read an op-ed jay-z
wrote about a year and a half ago about
Meek Mill and probation and really
opened my eyes to this issue
I didn't realize probation and bail yeah
seventy percent of people in jail get
this in America this is from the nation
haven't been convicted of a crime on
seventy percent right I saw when mana
420 jelly gud made ten million dollar
bail he made it oh yeah so if you got
ten million dollars yet laying around
you're good the growth in our jail
population over the past thirty years is
due to the tension of people not yet
convicted and one reason is he was
saying Meek Mill committed a crime when
he was 19 it is time right still being
stalked right by the probation like - he
popped a wheelie do a video that was
like a probation violation put him back
in the slammer and as Jay points out in
that op-ed in the New York Times the
charges of dismiss and so on but the
judge had the discretion to still go
after him and then when you talk about
bail he made a jay-z made a great
documentary on kalief Browder a young
man in New York charged with a crime he
didn't have the money to cash bail out
so he goes to Rikers for three years and
then he's abused by both fellow
prisoners and by the law enforcement
agencies there he gets out and he
eventually kills himself because he
couldn't deal with it I mean that's the
consequence of some of our untoward
policies that jay-z has used his
brilliance to illuminate as well
you